Brilliant minds,
even mediocre minds operate better under
stimulus.
Canadian is a Canadian.
If you can't take away,
mama has systematically rebuild the
trust of the world in our willingness to
work through the Security Council and
other incidence rate.
You must not talk to anybody in the
world,
any of our allies.
If whatever you want to call this system
a mafia state of feudal empire,
it's a disaster for ordinary Russians,
brilliant minds.
Even mediocre minds operate better under
stimulus.
Canadian is a Canadian.
If you can't take away
my has systematically rebuilt the trust
of the world in our willingness to work
through the Security Council and other
institutions.
You must not talk to anybody in the
world,
any of our allies,
if whatever you want to call this system
a mafia,
state of feudal empire,
it's a disaster for ordinary Russians.
I think that's the kind of hypocritical
argument that if I were Chinese,
I find quite annoying for the Chinese
leg can be described.
The in management,
science and religion are not
incompatible.
We're indigenous forces,
nice people to do unkind things.
Amen.
Obsolete and my conclusion to this
question is,
no,
I won't let you be.
You show me your work pretext.
I quoted them saying,
show me how you can keep screaming and
it doesn't change the point.
We do not want sympathy.
We do not want pity.
We want opportunities.
It's an appalling splenda to me,
to the Muslim religion.
I never said the word Muslim in my film
nation.
It was a Muslim free foam in it.
Is that kind of restraint?
It is that kind of sober minded,
sensible,
intelligent,
foreign policy that Obama represents.
So I guess what I'm telling you is he
sort of a closet Canadian vote for him.
For God.
Ladies and gentlemen and welcome,
my name is right here,
Griffis.
Since my privilege to have the
opportunity to
moderates tonight's debate and to act as
your organizer,
I want to start by welcoming the North
American wide television audience tuning
in right now across Canada on Seapak,
Canada's public affairs channel c span
across the continental United States and
on CBC radio ideas,
a warm hello also to our online audience
watching this debate.
Over 6,000
streams active at this moment on
facebook live on Bloomberg Dot Com and
munk debates stock.
Com.
It's great to have you as virtual
participants in tonight's proceedings
and hello to you the over 3000 people
who filled Roy Thompson Hall for yet
another monk debate.
Thank you for your support for more and
better debate on the big issues of the
day.
This debate marks the start of our 10th
season and we begin this season missing
someone who was vital to this debate
series in every aspect.
It was his passion for ideas,
his love for debate that inspired our
creation in 2008,
and it was his energy,
his generosity and his drive that was so
important in allowing us to really win
international acclaim as one of the
world's great debating series,
his philanthropy.
It's legacy.
Wow.
It's incredible.
Last fall,
we all remember that $100,
million dollar donation to cardiac
health here in Toronto,
transforming the lives of tens of
thousands.
It's a million Canadians to come.
We're all big fans and supporters of a
terrific school for global affairs on
the UFT campus represented here tonight
by many students are in a master's
program.
Congratulations
you
also what a generous endowment last
spring to this series that will allow us
to organize many evenings like this for
many more years to come.
Now knowing our benefactor as we.
The last thing he'd want is for us to
mark his absence with a moment of
silence.
That wasn't his style,
so let's instead celebrate a great
Canadian,
a great life,
and a great legacy of the late Peter
Munk.
Bravo keytar.
Thanks Peter.
Thanks.
I know he would have enjoyed that and I
want to just thank Melanie Anthony
Chainy for being here tonight to be part
of Peter's continuing positive impact on
public debate in Canada.
Thank you
for being here tonight.
Now,
knowing Peter as I did the first thing
on his mind at this point in the debate
would be right here.
Stop talking.
Get this debate underway.
Get our debaters out here.
Come on,
get the show on the road.
So we're going to do that right now
because we have a terrific debate lined
up for you this evening.
So let's introduce first our pro team
arguing for tonight's motion.
Be it resolved what you call political
correctness.
I call progress.
Please welcome to the stage.
He's an award winning writer,
scholar broadcaster on MPR and sports
networks across America.
Michael,
Eric Dyson.
come on out.
Thank you.
Michael is debating.
Partner is also an award winning author.
She's a columnist at the New York Times
and someone who is going to bring a very
distinct and powerful perspective
tonight.
Michelle Goldberg.
Michelle,
come on out.
Thank you.
So one great team of debaters deserves
another and arguing against our
resolution.
Be it resolved what you call political
correctness.
I call progress is the Emmy Award
winning actor,
screenwriter,
author,
playwright,
journalist,
poet,
and tonight debater.
Stephen Fry.
Thank you.
Steven's teammates is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto,
a youtube sensation and the author of
the big new international bestseller,
12 rules for life.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Toronto's Jordan Peterson.
Thank you.
Okay,
we're
gonna.
Get our debate underway momentarily,
but first,
a quick checklist to go through.
We've got a hashtag tonight hash at munk
debates.
Those of you in the hall and those of
you watching online,
please a win.
Let's get your opinions going.
Also,
for those of you watching online right
now,
we have an ad running pole,
a ww munk debates.com.
Forward slash votes reflect,
input,
react to this debate as it unfolds over
the next hour and a half.
Uh,
my favorite part aspect of this show
that was Peter's brilliance and
creation,
we have our countdown clock.
What this does is it keeps our debaters
on their toes and our debate on time.
So when you see these clocks on the
screen,
go down to zero,
wanted you to join me in a warm round of
applause and we'll have a debate that
ends when it's supposed to end a.
now,
let's see,
we had our resolution tonight on the way
in.
We had this audience of roughly 3000
people here in downtown Toronto vote on
be it resolved or what you call it,
political correctness.
I call progress.
Let's see the agree,
disagree on that.
Number.
Thirty six percent agree.
Sixty four percent disagree.
So room and play.
Now we asked you how many of you are
open to changing your vote over the
course of debate?
Are you fixed,
agree,
disagree,
or could you potentially be convinced by
one or other of these two teams to move
your vote over the next hour and a half?
Let's see those numbers now.
Wow.
Okay.
A pretty open minded crowd.
This debate is very much in play and as
per the agreed upon order of speakers.
I'm going to call and Michelle Goldberg
first.
Michelle,
would you like I said,
well,
what are you gonna?
Have a sip of water before you start a
column.
Michelle Goldberg first for her.
Six minutes of opening remarks.
Michelle,
thank you for having me.
And as I initially bumped a little bit
at the resolution that we're debating
because there are a lot of things that
fall under the rubric of political
correctness that I don't call a
progress.
I don't like no platforming or twitter
or trigger warnings.
Um,
you're like a lot of
middle aged liberals.
There are many aspects of students'
social justice culture that I find off
putting,
although I'm not sure that that
particular generation gap is anything,
is anything new.
I'm on the record about the toxicity of
social media,
call out culture,
and I think it's good to debate people
whose ideas I don't like,
which is why I'm here.
Um,
so if there are social justice warriors
in the audience,
I feel like I should apologize to you
because I'm probably not.
You're probably gonna feel like I'm not
adequately defending your ideas,
but the reason I'm on this side of the
stage is that political correctness
isn't just a term for left wing excesses
on college campuses or people being
terrible on twitter,
especially as deployed by Mr Peterson.
I think it can be a way to diligence
itemize any attempt for women and racial
and sexual minorities to overcome
discrimination were even to argue that
such discrimination is real in the New
York Times today.
Mr Peterson says,
quote,
the people who hold that,
that our culture isn't an oppressive
patriarchy.
They don't want to admit that the
current hierarchy might be predicated on
competence.
That sounds particularly insane to me
because I'm an American and our
president is Donald Trump,
but um,
but it's an assumption that I think
underlies a worldview in which any
challenges to the current hierarchy are
written off as political correctness.
I also think we should be clear that
this isn't really a debate about free
speech.
Um,
Mr Peterson once referred to what he
called quote that evil trinity of
equity,
diversity and inclusivity,
and said those three words,
if you hear people mouth those three
words,
equity,
diversity,
and inclusivity,
you know who you're dealing with,
and you should step away from that
because it is not acceptable.
He argues that the movie frozen is
politically correct propaganda.
And at one point he floated the idea of
creating a database of university course
content so students could avoid
postmodern critical theory.
So in the criticism of political
correctness,
I sometimes hear an urge or an attempt
to purge our thought of certain
analytical categories that mirrors,
I think the worst characatures of the
social justice left,
that wants to get rid of anything that
smacks of colonialism or patriarchy or
white supremacy.
I also don't really think we're debating
the value of the enlightenment,
at least not in the way that somebody
like Mr Frye.
Well,
I think as a champion of enlightenment,
values frames it,
the efforts to expand rights and
privileges once granted just to land
owning white heterosexual men is the
enlightenment or is very much in keeping
with the enlightenment.
To quote a dead white man,
John Stuart Mill,
the despotism of custom is everywhere,
the standing hindrance to human
advancement.
Um,
I think that some of our opponents by
contrast frame challenges to the
despotism of customs as politically
correct attacks on a transcendent
natural order.
To quote Mr Peterson again,
each gender,
each sector has its own unfairness to
deal with.
But to think of it as a consequence of
the shoulders of the social structure,
it's like,
come on really what about nature itself?
But there is an exception to this
because he does believe in social
interventions to remedy some kinds of
unfairness,
which is why in the New York Times he
calls for quote enforcement Origami to
remedy the woes of men who don't get
their equal distribution of sex.
Um,
when it comes to the political
correctness debate,
we've been exactly here before Alan
Blum,
the author of the clothing of the
American mind compared the tyranny of
feminism in academia to the Khmer Rouge,
and he was writing at a time when women
accounted for 10 percent of all college
tenured faculty.
It's worth looking back at what was
considered annoyingly outrageously
politically correct in the 19 eighties.
The last time we had this debate,
you know,
having to call or not being able to call
indigenous people,
quote Indians are having to use
hyphenated terms,
at least in the United States,
have terms like African Americans,
you know,
adding women or people of color to the
western Civ curriculum.
Not Making gay jokes or using retard is
an epithet.
And I kind of get it right.
New concepts,
new words sort of sticking your throat
the way we're used to talking and
thinking seem natural and normal,
you know,
by definition.
And then the new terms,
new concepts that have social utility
stick and those that don't fall away.
So if you go back to the 19 seventies,
ms,
you know,
ms as an alternative to Mr Mrs stuck
around and women with a y didn't.
Um,
and I think that some day I hope that
someday we'll look back and marvel at
the idea that gender neutral pronouns
ever seen like an existential threat to
anyone,
but I also don't think it's clear that,
you know,
that might not happen because if you
look around the world right now,
there are plenty of places that have
indeed dialed back cosmopolitanism and
reinstated patriarchy in the name of
staving off chaos.
And they seem like terrible places to
live.
Um,
you know,
I come to you from the United States,
which is currently undergoing a
monumental attempt to roll back social
progress in the name of overcoming
political correctness.
And as someone who lives there,
I assure you,
it feels nothing like progress.
Thank you.
Great.
Start to the debate,
Michelle.
Thank you.
I'm now gonna.
Ask Jordan Peterson to speak for the con
team.
Hello.
So we should first decide what we're
talking about.
We're not talking about my views of
political correctness despite what you
might have inferred from the last
speaker's comments.
This is how it looks to me.
We essentially need something
approximating a low resolution grant
narrative to unitus and we did narrative
to united because otherwise we don't
have peace.
What's playing out in the universities
and in broader society right now is a
debate between two fundamental low
resolution narratives.
Neither of which can be completely
accurate because they can't encompass
all the details.
Obviously human beings have an
individual element and a collect
development.
A group element.
Let's say the question is what story
should be paramount,
and this is how it looks to me in the
West.
We have reasonably functional,
reasonably free,
remarkably productive stable hierarchies
that are open to consideration of the
dispossessed that hierarchies generally
create.
Our societies are freer and functioning
more effectively than any societies,
anywhere else in the world and that and
then any societies ever have and as far
as I'm concerned,
and I think there's good reason to
assume this,
it's because the fundamental low
resolution,
a grant narrative that we've oriented
ourselves around in the West is one of
the sovereignty of the individual and
it's predicated on the idea that all
things considered the best way for me to
interact with someone else's individual
to individual and to react to that
person as if they are both a part of the
process because that's the right way of
thinking about it.
The psychological process by which
things we don't understand can yet be
explored and buy.
Things that aren't properly organized in
our society can be yet set.
Right,
and the reason we're valuable as
individuals,
both with regards to our rights and
responsibilities,
is because that's our essential purpose.
Announce our nobility and that's our
function.
What's happening as far as I'm concerned
in the universities in particular and
spreading very rapidly out into the
broader world,
including the corporate world,
much to.
It's a much to what should be its
chagrin is a collectivist narrative and
of course there's some utility in a
collectivist narrative because we're all
part of groups in different ways,
but the collectivist narrative that I
regard as politically correct as a
pastiche of a strange pastiche of
postmodernism in neo Marxism in its
fundamental claim is that no,
you're not essentially an individual.
You're essentially a member of a group
and that group might be your ethnicity
and it might be your sex and it might be
a race and it might be any of the
endless numbers of other potential
groups that you belong to because you
belong to many of them and that you
should be essentially categorized along
with those who are like you on that
dimension in that group.
That's proposition number one.
Proposition number two is that the
proper way to view the world is as a
battle ground between groups of
different power.
So you defined the groups first and then
you assume that you,
you view the individual from the group
context.
You viewed the battle between groups,
from the group context and you view
history itself.
As a consequence of nothing but the
power maneuvers between different
groups,
that eliminates any consideration of the
individual and at a very fundamental
level and also any idea,
for example,
of free speech because if you're
collectivist had heart in this manner,
there is no such thing as free speech.
It isn't that it's debated by those on
the radical left and let's say the rest
of us so to speak.
It's that in that formulation there's no
such thing as free speech because for an
individualist free speeches,
how you make sense of the world and
reorganize society in a proper manner,
but for the radical left type
collectivist that's associated with this
viewpoint of political correctness.
When you speak,
all you're doing is playing a power game
on behalf of your group and there's
nothing else that you can do because
that's all there is and not only is that
all there is in terms of who you are as
an individual now and how society should
be viewed.
It's also the fundamental narrative of
history.
For example,
it's.
It's widely assumed in our universities
now that the best way to conceptualize
Western civilization is as an oppressive
male dominated patriarchy and that the
best way to construe relationships
between men and women across the
centuries is one of oppression of women
by men as like,
well,
look,
no hierarchy is without it's tyranny.
That's a.
that's an axiomatic truth.
People have recognized that literally
for thousands of years and hierarchies
do tend towards tyranny and they tend
towards the use of patient by people
with power,
but that only happens when they become
corrupt and we have mechanisms in our
society to stop hierarchies from
becoming intolerable.
He corrupted.
They actually work pretty well and so
and so.
I would also.
I would also point this out,
you know,
don't be thinking that this is a debate
about whether empathy is useful or not
or that the people on the con side of
the argument are not empathetic.
I know perfectly well as I as an
insured,
Mr Frye does that.
Hierarchies tend to produce situations
where people stack up at the bottom and
that the dispossessed and hierarchies
need a political voice,
which is the proper voice of the left by
the way and the necessary voice of the
left,
but that is not the same as proclaiming
that the right level of analysis for our
grand unifying narrative is that all of
us are fundamentally to be identified by
the groups that we belong to and to
construe the entire world has the
battleground between different forms of
tyranny in consequence of that group
affiliation and to the degree that we
play out that narrative that won't be
progress.
Believe me,
and we certainly haven't seen that
progress in the universities.
We've seen situations like what happened
at Wilfrid laurier.
Instead,
we won't see progress.
What will return to is exactly the same
kind of tribalism to characterize the
left.
Thank you,
Jordan.
Michael,
Eric Dyson.
Your six minutes starts now.
Thank you very kindly.
Wonderful opportunity to be here in
Canada.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to stand here at the podium.
I'm a preacher and I will ask for an
offering.
At the end of my presentation,
this is the swimsuit competition of the
intellectual beauty pageant,
so let me show you the curves of my
fault.
Oh my God.
Was that a politically incorrect
statement I just made?
How did we get to the point where the
hijacking of the discourse on political
correctness has become a kind of
Mandakini distinction between us and
them?
The abortive fantasy just presented is
remarkable for both its clarity and yet
the muddiness of the context from which
it has emerged.
What's interesting to me is that when we
look at the radical left,
I'm saying where they I want to join
them.
They didn't run enough,
and I'm from a country where a man
stands up everyday to suite the moral
mendacity of his viciousness into a
nation.
He has turned into his psychic commode.
Y'All got Justin?
We got Donald.
So what's interesting then is that
political correctness as transmogrified
into a caricature of the left.
The left came up with the term political
correctness.
Shall I remind you,
we were tired of our excuses in our
excesses and are exaggerations.
We were willing to be so critical in a
way that I fear my confreres.
My compatriots are not.
Don't take yourself too seriously.
Smiles.
Take yourself seriously at all,
but what you do with deadly seriousness,
now it is transmogrified into an attempt
to characterize the radical left.
The radical left is a metaphor.
It's a symbol as an articulation.
They don't exist.
They're numbers are too small.
I'm on college campuses.
I don't see much of them coming.
When I hear about identity politics,
that amazes me.
The collectivist identity politics,
uh,
last time I checked white folk have been
at race.
That was an invention from a dominant
culture that wanted groups to at their
behest,
the invention of race was driven by the
demand of a dominant culture to
subordinate others.
Patriarchy,
patriarchy.
Patriarchy was the demand of men to have
their exclusive vision presented.
The beauty of feminism is it's not going
to resolve differences between men and
women.
It just sends me,
I don't automatically get the last word.
Of course they never did.
And so identity politics has been
generated as a bet noir of the right and
yet the right doesn't understand the
degree to which identity has been
foisted upon black people and Brown
people and people of color from the very
beginning on women and Trans People.
You think that I want to be part of a
group that is constantly at port by
people at starbucks.
I'm minding my own business,
walking down the street.
I have group identity thrust upon me.
They don't say,
Oh,
there goes a negro.
Highly intelligent,
articulate,
verbose,
capable of rhetorical fury at the drop
of a hat.
We should not interrogate him as to the
bone of the days of his legal sentence.
No,
they treat me as part of a group.
And the problem is that our friends
don't want to acknowledge is that the
head Gemini,
that dominance of that group has been so
vicious that it is denied us the
opportunity to exist as individuals.
Individualism is the characteristic
moment in modernity.
Ms Dot Peterson is right.
The development of the individual.
However,
it's predicated upon notions of
intelligence in mind.
You a continent,
David,
human,
others philosophically cart descartes,
comes along introducing knowledge into
the to the,
to the phrase saying that knowledge is
based upon the kind of reference to the
golden intelligence,
the reflective glass at one possesses,
and yet they get rooted in the very
ground of our existence,
so now it has fleshly basis and what I'm
saying to you,
the knowledge that I bring as a person
of color makes a difference in my body
because I know what people think of me
and I know how they respond to me and
that ain't no theory am I am I mad at
trigger warnings?
Only trigger warning.
Got One is from a cop.
Are you about to shoot me?
Not Funny in America where young black
people die repeatedly,
unarmed without provocation,
and so for me,
identity politics is something very
serious.
And what's interesting about safe
spaces,
I hear about the university,
I teach there.
Look,
if you in a safe space in your body,
you don't need a safe space.
Some of that is overblown.
Some of it is ridiculous.
I understand.
I believe that the classroom was a
robust place for serious learning.
I believe in the interrogation of
knowledge based upon our understanding
mutually edifying proposition of
enlightenment.
At the same time,
some people ain't as equal as others,
so we have to understand the conditions
under which they have emerged and in
which they have been benighted and
attacked by their own culture,
and I ain't seen nobody be a bigger
snowflake than white men who complain.
Mommy,
Mommy won't let us play and have
everything we used to have under the old
regime where we were right,
racist in some premises and dominant and
patriarchs and hated gays and lesbians.
Transsexuals that a,
yeah,
you gotta share this Angel World or
about his world,
and let me hear it by saying this.
You remember that story from David
Foster Wallace fish going down to fish
or going into an older fish comes in the
opposite direction.
He said,
hello boys.
How's the water?
They swim on.
They turn each other.
What the Hell is water?
Because when you're in it,
you don't know it.
When you're dominant,
you don't know nothing.
Keyser soze he said is more interesting,
but the devil did then to make people
believe he did
exist.
Thank you Michael.
Steven Europe.
So we're going to put six minutes on the
clock and please start again.
I'll try and be as quick as possible
because if I miss that plane to London,
I went half here,
the end of it from the bridegroom's
groom's mother.
In agreeing to participate in this
debate and stand on this side of the
argument,
I'm fully aware that many people who
choose incorrectly in my view to to see
this issue in terms of left and right,
devalued unexploded terms.
I think they will believe that I am
portraying myself in such causes and
values that I have espoused over the
years.
I've been given a huge grief already
simply because I'm standing here next to
Professor Peterson,
which is the very reason that I am
standing here in the first place.
I'm standing next to someone with whom I
have no differences,
shall we say in terms of politics and
all kinds of other things.
Precisely because I think all this has
got to stop this rage,
resentment,
hostility,
intolerance,
above all this,
um,
with us or against us.
Certainty at Grand Canyon has opened up
in our world.
The fishier,
the crack grows wider every day.
Neither on each side can hear a word
that the other shrieks and nor do they
want to.
While these armies and propagandists in
the culture wars clash down below in the
enormous space between the two sides,
the people of the world tried to get on
with their lives.
Alternative baffled board and betrayed
by the horrible noises and explosions
that echo all around.
I think it's time for this toxic binary,
zero some madness to stop before we
destroy ourselves.
The nail my colors to the mast before I
get any further than this.
It's only polite to give you a sense of
where I come from.
I all my adult life,
I have been what you might call the left
ear,
a soft left liberal of the most hand
wringing milk soap,
milk,
toast,
variety.
Not a burning man.
The barricades socialist,
not even really a progressive with the
name.
I've been on marches,
but I've never quite dead wave placards
or banners.
Um,
am I alluded member of that band,
the,
an Sjw,
a social justice warrior.
I don't think highly of social injustice
I have to say,
but I characterize myself mostly as a
social justice warrior.
My intellectual heroes growing up were
Bertrand Russell and Ge.
More liberal thinkers,
people like that.
Writers like am forced to.
I believed,
and I think I still do believe in the
sanctity of human relations,
of the primacy,
of the heart and friendship and love and
common interest.
These are more personal interior beliefs
than they are political exterior
convictions,
more humanistic version of a religious
impulse.
I suppose.
I trust in humanity.
I believe in humanity.
I think I do,
despite all that has happened in the 40
years of my adulthood,
I am soft and I can easily be swept away
by heart to hearts and harder intellect.
I'm sometimes surprised to be described
as an activist,
but overtime I have energetically
involved myself with what you might call
causes.
I grew up knowing that I was gay.
Well,
in fact,
from the very first I knew I was gay.
I remember when I was born looking up
and saying,
that's the last time I'm going up.
One of those.
I'm a,
I'm
Jewish.
I'm Jewish.
So I have a natural.
I was horror,
racism.
Um,
I naturally,
I want racism,
misogyny,
homophobia,
transphobia,
xenophobia,
bullying,
bigotry,
intolerance of all humankind to end that
surely a given amongst all of us.
The question is how such a golden aim is
to be achieved.
My ultimate objection to political
correctness is not that it combines so
much of what I've spent a lifetime
losing and opposing preachiness with
great respect,
piety a self righteousness heresy,
hunting,
denunciation,
shaming,
assertion without evidence,
accusation,
inquisition censoring.
That's not why I'm incurring the wrath
of my fellow liberals by standing on
this side of the house.
My real objection is that I don't think
political correctness works.
I want to achieve,
I want to get to the Golden Hill,
but I don't think that's the way to get
there.
Um,
I believe one of the greatest human
failings is to prefer to be right,
than to be effective.
Political correctness
is always obsessed with how right it is
without thinking of how effective it
might,
it might be,
I wouldn't trust myself as a classical
libertarian,
but I do relish transgression,
dive deeply and instinctively distrust
conformity and orthodoxy.
Progress is not achieved by preachers
and guardians of morality,
but to paraphrase,
you have Guinea Zim,
yachting by madmen hermits,
heretics,
dreamers,
rebels,
and skeptics.
I may be wrong.
I hope to learn this evening.
I really do think I may be wrong,
but I'm prepared to entertain the
possibility that political correctness
will bring us more tolerance and a
better world,
but I'm not sure and I would like this
quotation from my hair,
a Bertrand Russell to hover over the
evening.
One of the painful things about our time
is that those who feel certainty are
stupid and those within the imagination
and understanding are filled with doubt
and indecision.
Thank
great set of opening statements to set
the scene.
We're now going to go into a round of
rebuttals to allow each of our
presenters three minutes to reflect on
what they've heard and to make some
additional points.
We're going to do that in the same order
that we had,
the opening statements.
So Michelle,
you're up first.
We'll put three minutes on the clock for
you.
So first I would say that I think that
the attempt to draw a dichotomy between
individual rights and group rights is a
little bit misleading.
I'm traditionally,
there has been large groups of people
who have not been able to exercise their
individual rights and I think that a lot
that the claims that are being made on
behalf of what we politically correct
types call marginalized groups are
claims that people who,
you know have identities that have not
traditionally been at the center of our
culture or been at the top of our
hierarchies have as much right to
exercise their individual talents and
realize their individual ambitions.
Right.
When we say that we want more women in
power or more people of color's voices
in the Canon or in the curriculum or you
know,
pete directing movies.
All of these things or not,
because at least on my part,
I'm interested in some sort of very
crude equity,
but because there are a lot of people
who have not traditionally been able to
realize themselves as individuals,
that's what the women's movement was.
That's what the civil rights movement
was.
That's what the gay rights movement was.
That's in some ways what the Trans
Rights movement was.
I mean,
far from a collectivist movement.
This is kind of liberalism.
Classical liberalism pushed to its
extreme right.
These are people saying,
I have the to define my identity against
the one that was collectively assigned
to me.
Finally,
I would say,
you know,
a lot of the things that Stephen Fry
said,
you know,
in particularly his temperament,
we're probably in agreement,
but this inquisition,
this censorious snus.
On the one hand,
I'm sort of,
I see where he's coming from,
but I think it's a little bit virtual,
right?
I mean,
no know who's,
who's really censoring you.
Um,
I understand what it feels like to feel
censored.
I understand what it feels like to be on
the wrong side of a twitter mob or get a
lot of nasty comments,
but,
and that's a bad feeling,
you know,
and it's a counterproductive tactic,
but that's not censorship.
Um,
you know,
and again,
it's,
it's especially strange coming from a
country where,
you know,
the president of the United States is
trying to levy additional postal rates
on the owner of the Washington Post,
you know,
in revenge for its reporting.
And people who have kneeled to protest
police brutality at football games have
seen their careers explode,
you know,
or people who have women who have
challenged Mr Peterson has been hounded
by threats and trolls and misogynists
invective.
So
thank you Jordan.
We're going to have three minutes up on
the screen there.
Please respond to what you've heard.
Well,
I guess I would like to set out a
challenge in,
in somewhat the same format as Mr Frye
did to people on the moderate left.
I mean I've studied totalitarianism for
a very long time,
both on the left and on the right in
various forms.
And I think we've done a pretty decent
job of determining when right wing
beliefs become dangerous,
I think that they become dangerous when
they,
in the people who stand on the right
evoke notions of of racial superiority,
superiority or ethnic superiority,
something like that.
It's fairly easy to draw a box around
them and place them to one side and
necessary.
And I think we've done a pretty good job
of that.
What I failed to see happening on the
left,
and this is with regards to the sensible
left because such a thing exists,
is for the same thing to happen with
regards to the radical leftists.
Okay.
So here's an open question.
If it's not diversity,
inclusivity and equity as a triumvirate
that mark out the to excessive left and
with equity defined by the way,
not as equality of opportunity,
which is an absolutely laudable goal,
but as equality of outcome,
which is how it's defined then exactly
how do we demarcate the two extreme
left,
what do we do?
And we say,
well,
there's no such thing as the two extreme
left.
Well,
that's certainly something that
characterizes much of intellectual
thinking for the 20th century as our
high order intellectuals,
especially in place like places like
France did,
everything they could to bend over
backwards to ignore absolutely
everything that was happening in the
catastrophic left world in the Soviet
Union and China not least.
We've done a terrible job of determining
how to demarcate what's useful from the
left,
from what's pathological and so it's
perfectly okay for someone to criticize
my attempts to identify something like a
boundary.
We could say diversity,
inclusivity and equity,
especially equity,
which is in fact equality of outcome,
which is an absolutely a boren notion.
If you know anything about history,
you know that and I'm perfectly willing
to hear some reasonable alternatives,
but what I hear continually from people
on the left,
first of all,
as my opponents did,
to construe every argument that is
possibly able to be construed on the
axis of group identification and it
failed to defer to,
to fail to help the rest of us
differentiate the reasonable left,
which stands for the oppressed
necessarily from the pathological left
that's capable of unbelievable
destruction.
And what I see happening in the
university campuses in particular where
the left is absolutely predominate and
that's certainly not my imagination.
That's that's well documented by
perfectly reasonable people like
Jonathan Haidt is an absolute failure to
make precisely that distinction.
And I see the same thing tonight.
Thank you.
Well,
give us your rebuttal.
Let me step out here.
And Peterson land.
Oh,
I feel free already.
I don't know what mythological
collective Mr Peterson refers to.
I'm part of the left.
Their content garous when they have a
firing squad,
is usually in a semicircle.
Part of the skepticism of rationality
was predicated upon the enlightenment
project,
which says,
we're no longer going to be subordinate
to skepticism to superstition.
We're going to think and we're going to
think,
well,
Thomas Jefferson was one of the great
arbiters of rationality,
but he was also a man who was a slave
owner.
How do you reconcile that?
That's the complication I'm speaking
about.
That's not either or.
That's not a collective identity.
Thomas Jefferson believed in the
collective identity.
That is during the day at night,
he got some luther vandross songs,
went out to the slave quarter and
engaged in sexual relations and had many
children with sally hemings his lines.
Trump is logic and when he hit talks
about postmodernism,
I don't know who he's talking about.
I teach.
Postmodernism is Kinda fun.
Jacques Derrida,
just to say his name is beautiful.
Michelle Michel.
Foucault talks about the insurrection of
subjugated knowledge is people who had
been marginalized.
Now begin to speak.
The subaltern is gaietry.
Speeback talks about it in postcolonial
theory.
The reason these people grew up and grew
into existence and had a voice is
because they were denied.
As Ms Dot Goldberg said,
our group identity was foisted upon us.
We were not seen as individuals.
Babe Ruth,
when he broke the home run home run
record.
He didn't bat against all basketball
players.
He batted against the best white
ballplayers.
When it's been rigged in your favor from
the very beginning,
it's hard for you to understand how much
you've been.
Rick,
you're born on third base.
Thank you.
Hit a triple at the Toronto Blue Jays
game,
and here we are deriving our sense of
identity from the very culture that we
ignore.
Look at the indigenous names and the
first nation names,
Toronto,
Saskatchewan,
Winnipeg,
Tim Horton's,
but I'll tell you,
there's an envy of the kind of freedom
and liberty that people of color and
other minorities bring because we bring
the depth of knowledge in our body.
There's a kind of jealousy event as the
greatest living Canadian philosopher
Aubrey Drake Graham says,
jealousy is just love and hate at the
same time,
and so for me,
I think it's necessary.
I agree with Mr Frye.
We shouldn't be nasty and combative and
yet I don't see nastiness and
combativeness from people.
I see them making a desire to have their
individual identities respected.
When I get shot down,
for no other reason that I'm black,
when I get categorized for no other
reason than my color,
I am living in a culture that refuses to
see me as a great individual.
Yeah,
no,
it's interesting to hear that there
doesn't seem to be a problem,
but yet I think we all instinctively
know that there is some kind of problem.
There isn't sentence censorship ship,
of course.
Not In the way that there is in Russia.
I've been to Russia,
I've faced off with the,
uh,
deeply homophobic as unpleasant man and
there's political correctness in Russia
is just political correctness on the
right.
And that's what I grew up with,
political correctness,
which meant that you couldn't say
certain things on television,
couldn't say fuck,
for example,
on television because it was incorrect
to do so.
And there's always the same reason was
that someone would appear and say,
I'm not shocked.
Oh,
of course.
No,
I'm not shocked.
I'm not offended.
I'm offended on behalf of others.
Young,
impressionable plastic minds,
the vulnerable.
And that's not good enough.
It's,
it's.
So often people are saying,
see,
I don't mind being called a faggot or a
cake or whatever,
blue or mad person because they've got
mental health issues.
I don't mind people insulting me and
people say,
well,
that's all right for you,
Steven,
because you're new.
You're strong like I don't feel
particularly strong and I don't know
that I like being called a faggot and
the kite particularly,
but I don't believe that the advances in
my culture that have allowed me to marry
as I have now been for three years to
someone of my gender.
I don't believe they are a result of
political correctness and maybe
political correctness is actually just
some sort of live trout that the harder
we squeeze it,
the further it goes away and you will be
saying,
I'm not talking about physical retinas.
You're talking about social justice with
which I agree with where they want to
call it identity politics or the history
of your people.
In the history of my people,
my people were slaves as well.
Both the British were slaves of Romans
and the Jews were slaves to the
Egyptians.
All human beings have been slaves at
some point and we all in that sense
share that knowledge of how important it
is to speak up,
but Russell means who was a friend of
mine,
who was the one who founded the American
Indian movement.
He said,
oh,
I forgot to call me an Indian or a
Lakota Sioux or Russell,
I don't care what you call me.
It's how we're treated.
That matters,
and so I'm really addressing a more
popular idea.
Also actually in Barrow,
Alaska and Inupiaq said,
call me an Eskimo.
It's obviously easier for you because
you keep mispronouncing Inupiaq in a
words do matter.
I'll just end with a quick story.
A gay rights came about in England
because we slowly in persistently
knocked on the door of people in power.
We didn't shout.
We didn't scream.
People like Ian mckellen eventually got
to see the prime minister and when the
Queen signed in the royal assent,
she has to for the bill allowing
equality of marriage.
She said,
Lord,
you know,
I couldn't imagine this in 1953.
Really is extraordinary,
isn't it?
Just wonderful and handed it over.
Now that's a nice story and I hope it's
true,
but it's nothing to do with political
correctness.
It's to do with human decency.
It's that simple.
Thank you.
Great
rebuttals.
They're strong opening statements.
Let's move now into the,
uh,
the moderated,
a cross examination portion of this
debate and get both sides engaging on
some of the key issues here.
And I think what we've heard here is a
bit of a attention.
Let's draw it out a bit more between,
uh,
the rights of groups to feel included,
to have,
in your words,
Michelle,
the opportunity for individuality and a
belief on the other side that,
uh,
there's something,
a threat here when these groups are
overly privileged through affirmative
action or other outcome oriented
processes.
So Michael,
to start with you,
why,
why isn't there just harm that's done to
groups by privileging their group
identity,
whether it be a group identity of race
or gender and not immediately treating
them as,
and the way that
Jordan and Steven would like to see you
see them.
First will,
a couple of things.
First of all,
there was no arbitrary and random
distinction that people of color and
other minority groups made when I talked
about the invention of race,
the invention of gender,
the invention of group think that was
not done by those groups that have been
so named as Ms Dot Goldberg said,
so first of all,
you've got to acknowledge the historical
evolution of that reality and the
concept of group identity did not begin
with them.
It began with a group that didn't have
to announce its identity.
When you are in control,
you don't have to announce who you are
so that many white brothers and sisters
don't see themselves as one among many
other ethnicities or groups.
What they see themselves as,
I'm just American,
I'm Canadian.
Can't you be like us?
Can't you transcend those narrow group
identifications and yet those group
identifications have been imprinted upon
them by the very people who now because
they are their group power has been
challenged.
Let's make no mistake about it.
There is a challenge.
I,
I agree with Mr.
Fry in a kind of neverland of how sweet
it would be to have a kingly and cleanly
a metaphor about how it got resolved.
That ain't the real deal,
homie and in the real world and it and
in the real world,
there's stuff at stake.
What's at stake or bodies?
What's at stake or people's lives?
What's a sake?
People are still being lynched,
killed what's at stake.
People because of their sexuality and
their racial identity are still being
harmed,
so I'm suggesting to you,
it's not that we are against being
treated as individuals.
That's what we're crying for.
Please don't see me as a member of a
group that you think is a thug,
a nigger,
a nihilist,
a pathological person.
See me as an individual who embodies the
reality is if you are,
but I'll end by saying this.
What Michelle said is extremely
important.
The people who have individual rights
didn't have to fight for them in the
same manner that people of color and
others have had to.
When Mr Fried talked about enslavement,
he named them read Orlando Patterson's
comparative history of race and slavery.
Over 28 civilizations,
the Greeks did not have the same kind of
slavery that Americans said it was
chattel slavery in Greece.
You could buy back your,
your your freedom.
You could teach the children of the
people who enslaved you and because of
your display of prodigious intellect,
you could secure your freedom.
That was not the case.
You were punished and killed for
literacy in America,
so my point simply is this,
is that I am all for the celebration of
broader identities and I think that
often those who are minorities and
others are not celebrated for the degree
that we are out in.
By saying this in America,
we have the confederate flag.
I don't know if y'all are familiar with
that.
We have a confederate flag.
We have white guys mostly in the south,
but others as well,
flagging those confederate flags that
are part of the south that refuse to
seed.
It's legitimate.
A conquest at the hands of the.
There has been a politics of resentment.
Every you talking about politics of
identity wearing that flag,
not the American flag.
They are not American.
They are celebrating a succession.
A move away from America and a man named
Colin Kaepernick who was a football
player saying,
I want to bring beauty to that flag has
been denied opportunity,
so we have to really set the terms of
debate in order.
Before we.
We proceed.
Thank you.
Jordan.
Let's have you jump in on this idea of,
of
what you see as the pernicious danger of
group think when it comes to ethnicity,
when it comes to gender.
Why do you think that that's one of the
primal sins in your view of of political
correctness?
Well,
I think it's one of the primal sins of
identity politics players on the left
and the right.
Just to be clear about that personally,
since this has got personal at times,
I'm no fan of the identitarian right.
I think that anybody who plays a game of
conceptual game where group identity
comes first and foremost,
risks and exacerbation of tribalism,
it doesn't matter whether it's on the
left or the right with regards to the
idea of group.
Right?
Well,
there's a fundamental,
and this is something we've fallen into
terribly in Canada,
not least because we had to contend with
the threat of Quebec separatism,
but the idea of group writes is
extraordinarily problematic because the
the verse of the coin of individual
rights as individual responsibilities
and you can hold an individual
responsible and an individual can be
responsible and so that's partly why
individuals have rights,
but groups.
How do you hold a group responsible?
I mean the whole idea is not.
It's not a good idea to hold a group
responsible if first of all,
it flies in the face of the idea of the
sort of justice systems that we've laid
out in the West that are essentially
predicated first on the assumption of
individual innocence,
but also on the possibility of
individual guilt,
not group guilt.
We saw what happened in the 20th century
many,
many times when the idea of group guilt
was it was it.
It was enabled to get a foothold,
let's say,
in the policy and in the justice system
was absolutely catastrophic and so,
okay,
fine group rights,
well,
what are you gonna?
How are you going to contend with the
alternative to that,
the opposite of that,
or where's the group responsibility and
how are you going to keep,
how are we going to hold your group's
responsible?
Well,
we don't have to talk about that because
we're too concerned with rectifying
hypothetical rep rectifying historical
injustices,
hypothetical and otherwise,
and that's certainly not to say that
there weren't any shortage of absolutely
catastrophic historical injustices.
That's not the point.
The point is how you view the situation
at the most fundamental level and group
rights are absolute catastrophe in my
opinion.
Come on,
Michelle
point.
Is this something you've written about?
The idea that in identity politics,
the identity of the group is absolutely
a valid part of the discourse and and
individuals could and should be seen and
participate in groups as they enter into
the civic space.
I'm not sure for
that.
We necessarily have to analogize from
individual the,
you know,
the opposite of individual rights is
individual responsibility.
I'm not sure that that analogy
necessarily holds for the groups.
I mean,
in,
in the United States,
and one of the things that I think is
complicated about this discussion is
that we're talking about three very
different cultural context,
three different histories,
three different kinds of legal regimes.
But in the United States,
I'm a great,
a huge part of our politics has been
groups struggling for rights for their
individual members.
Right?
I mean,
so women in the United States,
you know,
seeking the right to reproductive
control of their body,
um,
you know,
African Americans in the United States
seeking redress from police brutality or
discrimination or simply the kind of
tendency in America of white people to
call the police whenever they see an
African American in a place where they
don't think that they're supposed to be.
And you simply.
I don't see how you can contend with any
of those social problems if you see
society as just an ocean of atomized
individuals.
Um,
you know,
and again,
I,
I don't,
I don't think there's anything
pernicious about people banding together
on the basis of their common identity to
seek redress for discrimination and
exclusion.
I mean,
I think that that is everything that's
best about our democracy,
that is the definition of progress.
And so again,
I just,
I keep stumbling with the idea that this
is somehow tyrannical or that way lies
stolen ism.
Um,
and you know,
a lot of times people who are opposed to
political correctness talk about the
concept of category creep or is it,
is it kept not?
No.
Yeah,
Category Creek,
which is a concept that was originated
by a believer in Australian academic and
it's basically kind of a failure to draw
distinctions,
right?
So that you kind of can't see the
difference between say a KKK grand
wizard and a conservative like say Ben
Shapiro or you know,
that you kind of see everybody to your
right as you know,
fascist,
sexist to Tala,
Terry and intolerable.
And I think that that is a real thing
that happens in part because,
you know,
undergraduates often thinking broad and
slightly overwrought categories.
I know I did when I was,
when I was a kid.
Um,
yeah,
maybe they'll do,
but,
but I,
I hear a lot of category creep in,
again,
the argument against political
correctness or against seeking group
redress the idea that kind of that way
lies dehumanization or you know,
that you're kind of one minute,
you're asking
what's up,
steven?
Come in on this part of your opening
remarks.
Your,
you're a category creep.
Steven didn't respond to that.
It's a nice.
I'm,
I'm still very lost about why we aren't
talking about political correctness.
We're talking about politics and the.
That's fine.
Shared exactly what you think about it.
I'm not an enemy of identity politics
per se.
I can obviously see where it goes wrong
and where it's annoying.
Let's be empirical about this.
How well is it working for you in
America at the moment?
Not well at all.
Really isn't.
You can ask me in a moment.
The reason,
the reason that trump and brexit in
Britain and all kinds of nativist all
over Europe and succeeding is not the
time for the right.
It's the catastrophic failure of the
left.
It's our fault.
My point is
that I turned to the right or anything
like that or that I'm nice and fluffy
and want everybody to be decent.
I'm saying,
fuck,
political correctness.
Resist fight.
If you have a point of view,
fight it in the proper manner.
Using democracy shouldn't be not channel
of education,
not language.
It's so silly.
There's a rule you know in chess,
the best move to playing chess is not
the best chess move.
It's the move your opponent least wants
you to play at the moment you're being
recruiting sergeant for the right,
annoying and upsetting,
and instead of fighting either fighting
or persuading,
but political correctness is a middle
course that simply doesn't work well.
First of all,
be empirical,
empirical,
as far as I know the word means that
which can be verified and falsified
through the sense executive,
so if we look at it in an objective way,
the reality is that people don't have
equal access to the means to articulate
that very moment.
You're talking about,
I'm talking about the empirical results
of this political attitudes.
I understand that,
but my point is simply this,
I'm suggesting to you that people use
the weapons at hand.
Now it was apprehend Joshua Heschel,
rabbi,
who said everybody's not guilty,
but everybody's responsible,
right?
That's a distinction there.
Everybody clearly is not guilty,
but what's interesting,
look at the flip side.
If you have benefited from 300 years of
holding people in servitude thinking
that you did it all on your own,
why can't these people work harder?
Let me see.
For 300 years you ain't had no job.
So the reality is for 300 years you old
people in the bands,
you hold them insubordination,
you refuse to give them rights.
Then all of a sudden you free them and
say you're now individuals.
Not having the skills reflect,
literally not having skills receptive
about America.
First of all,
I'm talking about American society.
I'm talking about the northern
hemisphere.
I'm talking about every society where
enslavement has existed,
but I'm speaking specifically of the
repudiation of individual rights among
people of Color in America who were
denied the opportunity to be
individuals.
So I see.
I obviously and ideally that Michelle
Goldberg does to agree with the emphasis
on individuals.
What we're saying to you is that we have
not been permitted to be individuals.
We have not been permitted to exercise
our individual autonomy and authority
and the refusal to do so.
To recognize me as an individual means
when you roll up on me and I'm a 12 year
old boy in a park and you shoot first in
ways you do the black kids that you
don't do the white kids.
You are not treating that person as an
individual.
If we're living in a society where women
are subject to abberant forms of horrid
to patriarchal,
sexist and massaged his behavior.
You are not acknowledging the centrality
of the individuality of women.
You are treating them according to eight
group dynamic and if we.
If we get beyond the ability of people
on the right to understand the degree to
which they have operated from the basis
of benefit from group identity without
having said it,
by saying this,
the great American philosopher,
beyonce knowles say it,
that it has been said that racism is so
American.
That if you challenge racism,
you look like you're challenging
America.
We are challenging inequality,
we are challenging the refusal to see me
as an individual when we overcome that.
Have added.
We're all on here.
Just getting started here.
A couple of questions.
So let's let her sites folks are going
to go to Jordan then to us assume for a
moment that I benefited from my white
privilege.
Okay.
So let's assume that that's fine.
Yeah.
Well that's what you would say.
So,
um,
so let's
here.
Let's get precise this.
Okay.
Was that into very individual you let's
get precise about this.
Okay.
He's good.
Precise
degree.
Is My present present level of
attainment or achievement?
A consequence of my white privilege.
And I don't mean sort of.
I mean do you mean five percent?
Do you mean 15 percent?
Do you mean 25 percent?
Do you mean 75 percent?
And what do you propose?
I do about it.
How about a tax?
How about a tax that's like specialized
for me so that I can account for my damn
privilege.
You said that.
I thought about it.
Now let's get precise about one other
thing.
Okay.
We'll get precise.
How about one other thing?
Their sites?
Yeah.
Precise.
Precise,
yes.
So if,
if we can agree and we haven't,
that the left can go too far,
which it clearly can't.
Then how would my worthy opponents
precisely defined when the left that
they stand for has gone too far.
You didn't like equity,
equality of outcome.
I think that's a great marker.
But if you have a better suggestion and,
and won't sidestep the question.
So let's figure out how I can dispense
with my white privilege and so that you
can tell
me when the left has gone too far since
they clearly can.
And that's what this debate is about,
about political correctness.
It's about the left going too far and I
think it's gone too far in many ways and
I'd like to figure out exactly how and
when.
So the reasonable left could make it's a
sentence again and we could quit all
this nonsense.
Okay.
I will answer you,
but I just want to answer first because
you talked about,
you know,
this is how we got trump and this is the
failure of the left.
And so I know I'm a journalist.
I went to a ton of trump rallies during
the campaign in different parts of the
country and you're right,
everywhere I went,
I heard complaints about political
correctness,
you know,
far more than I heard complaints about
say Nafta.
But when you asked people what they
meant by political correctness,
you know,
they call it a woman that worked with
girl and she got mad at them and you
know,
they could,
you know,
you couldn't in public wonder aloud
whether the president of the United
States was really a Muslim.
Um,
you know,
they didn't like that they couldn't make
gay jokes anymore.
And so on the one hand,
you're right,
and I've written about this.
I think that when you try to suppress
that,
when people have these prejudices and
you try to suppress them,
it can create a kind of dangerous
counter reaction.
But I also think that,
you know,
what they were reacting to.
Again,
to go to,
go back to the title of this debate,
what they called political correctness,
you know,
the fact that they had to have this
urbain black president who they felt
talked down to that,
which is really what they meant.
I don't see a way around that because
that is,
like I said,
that's progress.
Um,
so to go to the,
to the question of when the left goes
too far,
I mean,
to me it's pretty easy violence and
censorship,
right?
I'm big against violence and I'm against
censorship the.
But I also looking around the world
right now when the idea that there is
this,
I understand again,
there is like a problem of kind of left
wing annoyance,
right?
There's a lot of things that kind of
people,
random people on the internet in
particular are able to swarm individuals
and turn kind of stray remarks and just
social media campaigns.
And this is often conflated with
political correctness and it's a bad
phenomenon.
I wish there was a way to put an end to
it.
I don't think there is no way to put an
end to it simply by having kind of
reasonable liberals are reasonable.
Socialists denounce it because it's just
a kind of awful phenomenon of modern
life and if you want to have a debate
about whether social media is terrible
for democracy,
I will be on the gay side.
Um,
but right now what we're really
disagree.
Well,
a couple of,
there's a couple I really disagreed,
but I'm going to go to Michael,
but the idea that the radical left poses
a greater threat than the radical right?
When you see fat,
like actual fascism ascendant all over
the world strikes me as something that
you can literally only believe if you
spend your life on college campuses.
Mike,
I want to come to you on those on
Jordan's point about how does he in a
sense get an equal voice in this debate
back if it is implied that his
participation brings with it this
baggage of white privilege that doesn't
allow him to see clearly the issues that
are before us with veterans to be
complicit in the problem itself.
Terminal logically,
you're beginning at a point,
this is already a productive and
controversial.
You're saying,
how can he get his equality?
Beck,
who you talking about?
Jordan Peterson trending number one on
twitter.
Jordan Peterson internationals in an
international best seller.
I want them to tweet something out about
me and my book.
Jordan Peterson,
right?
This is what I'm saying to you.
Why the rage,
Bruh you you're doing well,
but you're a mean man.
White man and you're going to get us
right and I have never seen so much wine
and snow flaking.
There's enough light in here to start a
vineyard and what I'm saying to you
empirically and precisely when you ask
the question about white privilege,
the fact that you ask it in the way you
did,
dismissive pseudoscientific,
non empirical and without justification
a day.
The truth is that white privilege
doesn't act according to a quantifiable
segments.
It's about the degree to which we are
willing as a society to grapple with the
ideals of freedom,
justice,
and equality upon which is based.
Number two was interesting to me.
You're talking about not having a
collective identity.
What do you call a nation?
Are you Canadian?
Are you Canadian by yourself?
Are you an individual or are you part of
a group?
When America have formed it's union,
it did so in opposition to another
group,
so the reality is is that those who were
part of group identities and politics
denied the legitimacy and validity of
those groups and the fact that they have
been created thusly and ben have
resentment against others.
All I'm asking for is the opportunity
that this quotation you talk about the
difference between quality of outcome
and equality of opportunity.
That's a state and retried argument.
Hackneyed phrase derive from the halcyon
days of the debate over affirmative
action.
Are you looking for outcomes that can be
determined equally or are you looking
for opportunity?
If you free a person after a whole long
time of oppression and say,
now you are free to survive.
If you have no skills,
if you have no quantifiable means of
existence,
what you have done is liberated them
into and all I'm suggesting to you,
Lyndon Baines Johnson,
one of our great presidents said,
if you start a man in a race,
100 years behind,
it is awfully difficult to catch up,
so I don't think Jordan Peterson is
suffering from anything except an
exaggerated sense of entitlement and
resentment and his own privilege is
invisible to him and it's manifest with
lethal intensity and ferocity right here
on stage.
Let me respond to that.
Well,
what I derived from that series of
rebuttals,
let's say is twofold.
The first is that saying that the
radical left goes too far when they
engage in violence is not a sufficient
response by any stretch of the
imagination because there are sets of
ideas and radical leftist thinking that
led to the catastrophes of the 20th
century and that was at the level of
idea,
not at the level of violent action.
It's a very straightforward thing to say
you're against violence.
It's like being against poverty.
It's like,
you know,
gender,
generically speaking,
decent people are against poverty and
violence.
It doesn't address the issue in the
least with regards to my privilege or
lack thereof.
I mean,
I'm not making the case that I haven't
had advantages in my life and
disadvantages in my life.
Like most people,
you don't know anything about my
background or where it came from.
It,
it doesn't matter to you because
fundamentally I'm a mean white man.
That's a hell of a thing to say.
Thanks.
Let me just say very,
very brief because I want to move on to
men and women.
Mad White comment was not predicated
upon my historical excavation of your
pay as it's based upon the evidence
vitriol with which you speak and the
denial of a sense of equanimity among
the combatants in an argument.
So thing again,
you're a mean man.
White man and the viciousness.
Okay.
It's recently changed the decks here.
Let's talk about,
uh,
another big factor of the so called
politically correct movement right now,
which is the me too movement and the
extent to which we've seen this
resurgence,
this awakening around would have been a
horrible series of systemic abuses and
injustices towards women.
Some people though Michelle would say
that we're in a cultural panic now,
that the pendulum has swung too far and
that there is a dangerous overreaction
going on where people's rights
reputations due process has been thrown
to the wind.
How do you respond to that?
Well,
first,
when people started seeing that within
like two weeks of the Harvey Weinstein
story is breaking,
right?
The Minute Harvey Weinstein's and
people actually act started actually
losing their jobs over this,
right?
Which was something quite new that men
with histories of really serious
predatory behavior where suddenly losing
their jobs,
everybody had known about it for a long
time and there had been a sort of
implicit impunity and suddenly that was
taken away and it created this cultural
earthquake.
And as soon as it did,
it created a lot of anxiety.
Like,
what if this goes too far?
Um,
you know,
I mean the me too movement was only a
couple months old when my newspaper
started running columns from people
saying why can't I criticized me to
which they were doing in my newspaper?
Um,
so on the one hand guest of course is
due process important.
Obviously.
I think that when you look at who has
actually lost their jobs,
who's actually lost their livelihoods,
I mean look around.
It's people.
It's not people in general on a mccarthy
is rumor.
It's people who took their dicks out at
work.
It's people who,
you know,
there was,
tens of millions of dollars of
settlements and they lost their dog for
four months and now they're staging
comebacks.
You know,
Bill O'reilly is about to get a TV show
on a new network.
So the idea that again,
this idea that kind of like men
everywhere feel like they can't talk
anymore and everybody's walking on
eggshells.
And I don't know,
maybe that's true in your offices.
It's not true where,
where I live,
you know,
and the me too movement has been
particularly active in,
in media,
you know,
there was this,
this thing,
I don't know how many of you guys read
about the shitty media mentalist,
I'm a woman,
wrote about,
she started this sort of open source
document where women could list men in
media that everybody knew about but
nobody had ever done anything about.
And it very quickly went public and
there was something sort of disturbing
in it,
right?
You don't like these anonymous
accusations floating around.
Um,
most feminists I know including myself,
were kind of freaked out by it and
thought it was unfair to have people's
reputations held up like this.
But if you look at what happened to the
men on the list,
nothing,
you know,
they still have their jobs.
I know men on that list.
I work with men on that list.
The people who actually,
people have only buying as far as I can
think in media.
The people who have lost their jobs and
lost their careers.
It's been for extremely serious
misbehavior,
documented by multiple women who had
corroborating witnesses.
And so again,
I understand this anxiety that relations
between men and women are changing.
Of course,
that causes a lot of cultural anxiety,
but I don't know that it's rooted in
anything real get his view on this.
Are we intercultural panic is the
response Michelle says commensurate with
the moment.
I'm very confused
by this.
I,
of course,
I recognize the best attitude Weinstein
in the monstrosity of his behavior.
Uh,
and it was shocking to me.
I actually worked for him the script
doctoring as it's called.
And I never had the bathroom pto for
pretty obvious reasons.
Um,
but it's grotesque and I can't imagine
how violent must be for such a powerful
man.
He was,
I used to play a game at the Cannes film
festival where it is.
Here's a power.
We're walking from one hotel,
the,
uh,
at the end of the,
all the way up to the palliative
festival.
You will get 10 points every time you
heard the word harvey.
Um,
I'm usually a 10 minute walk.
You'd have a 300 points because it was a
hobbies.
Got The script.
Harvey's got it.
Yeah.
I've got a meeting with Harvey at the
majestic,
uh,
in the afternoon.
He was immensely powerful and I think
that's obvious that someone in that
position,
uh,
abusing him,
threatening and a hindering the
livelihood of women is grotesque and in
the extreme,
but I have to tell you,
there is genuine feeling amongst many
people.
I know that we can't speak our minds.
We can't actually speak to the true New
Orleans,
the true depth of sexual romantic
feeling between men and women.
That's not a subject don't absolutely
expert on,
but it comes between men and men as
well.
Though I know when it's men and men,
you might say,
well that's different because they are
women who have had a different
experience in history and I don't want
to enter that particular field,
but I would say that that is real fear
in my business,
which is where this all started.
Showbiz does acting and so on.
Yeah.
People are rather afraid to speak about
a piece of very no publicity that's come
out or a statement that's been made.
You just go,
Yup,
absolutely.
And wait for the people to leave the
room before you can speak honestly with
your friends.
And that's,
I've never experienced that in my entire
60 years on this planet.
There's this feeling that,
uh,
and I'd not characterizing feminists as
an east German,
but it's like that the stars you're
listening,
you better be careful that listening.
And that's genuine feeling.
I'm saying that my hand on my heart,
I'm not saying it to make a point other
than the fact that it's true and it's
worrying,
but the sexual misadventures in horror
experiences worrying too.
So the two words and they're not solved.
Let's bring Jordan in on this because
you've written and commented about a
lot.
Thank you.
Well,
I think I'm going to point out two
things again.
The first is that my question about when
the,
when the left goes too far,
still hasn't been answered.
And then the second thing I'm going to
point out is that,
you know,
it's conceivable that I am a mean man.
You know,
I mean
maybe I'm meaner than some people are
not as mean as others.
I think that's probably more the case,
but I would say the fact that race got
dragged into that particular comment is
a better exemplar of what the hell I
think is wrong with the politically
correct left than anything else that
could have possibly happened.
Imagine the hurt,
the anxiety,
the insult that you might genuinely feel
according to what I felt was an
appropriate comment of description at
the moment of its expression.
But imagine now those hurt feelings and
wow,
okay.
You feel great.
You feel great about really different.
I'm not a victim.
I'm not hurt.
You're hurt.
Okay.
You wouldn't be a victim.
So what?
What's interesting is that whatever a
non traditional feelings of empathy you
endure at this particular point,
the point is imagined then the horrors
that so many of the others have had to
put up with for so long when they are
refused to acknowledge their humanity.
Now I take your point seriously,
so you're.
Let me.
Let me finish.
Let me finish up figuring out my
acquisition or.
Okay.
What I'm saying to you is that when you
said you were upset that I added the
element of race there,
right when I said mean Matt White Man.
Well,
what's interesting is that you may have
felt that you were being ascribed the
group identity to which you do not
subscribe.
You may have felt that you were being
unfairly judged according to your
particular race.
You may have felt that your individual
identity was being the smurfs by my
rather careless characterization of you,
all of which qualifies for a legitimate
response to me,
but also the point we've been trying to
make about the refusal to see our
individual existence as women,
as people of Color,
as first nation people in the light.
My point simply has been the reason I
talked about race and that particular
characterization because there's a
particular way in which I have come to a
city.
I don't know if there are a lot of black
people out here.
Not sure,
but I constantly come to places and
spaces that are not my natural habitat
other than intellectual engagement and
the love in the fury of rhetorical
engagement.
Yes,
but I often go into hostile spaces where
people will not vote in favor for my
particular viewpoint because I'm
interested as an individual of breaking
down barriers so that people can
understand just how complicated it is.
So what I'm saying to you is that I
would invite you in of the surrender of
your privilege to give you a specific,
a specific response.
Come with me to a black Baptist church,
come with me to a historically black
college.
Come to me to an to an indigenous first
nations community where we're able to
engage in some of the lovely
conversation but also to listen and hear
and when I added race to that,
I was talking about the historical
events,
inability to acknowledge others,
pains equally to the one that they are
presently enduring.
So
human being being loved,
but I stand by my comments.
Seeing the sorts of things that you're
talking about.
I happened to be an honorary member of
an indigenous family,
so don't tell me about what I should go
see with regards to depression.
You don't know anything about me.
You asked me a question,
I gave you a response.
You gave me a generic response.
Is Generic race pace or sports Jordan
Peterson?
I would like for you to come with me,
Michael,
Eric Dyson to a black Baptist church.
You've been.
I would be happy to do that,
but.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna Hook you up.
You have one more question.
Brandon.
We're going to go to closing statements
and Stephen for.
I want to get your response to why you
know a generation from now looking back
on this debate,
we're not going to see this quote,
so-called politically correct movement
in the same way.
Let's say that we now understand the
positive contributions of the civil
rights movement,
that that was a movement that advanced a
series of,
of ideas about human dignity to people
who previously didn't have that dignity.
We're now having another debate and
other social debate about different
groups and communities that are.
We're trying to convey a sense of,
of new dignity to them.
Why?
Why won't this be be in a sense looked
back upon as something positive a
generation from now.
I think people will look back on this
debate and wonder why political
correctness wasn't discussed.
Thanks.
Slippery.
I mean,
I
interesting to hear talk about race and
about gender and about to be quality and
it's something that I've thought about a
lot and I can learn a great deal about.
But that's not why I came to this debate
I was interested in,
um,
what I've always been interested in the
suppression of language and thought the
closing down the rationalist idea that
seems beguiling,
that if you limit people's language,
it made somehow teach them a different
way of thinking.
Something that would have delighted the
inventors of George Orwell's newspeak
for example.
And it seems to me it's just
implausible.
It doesn't,
it doesn't work.
And that's what I mean by empirical.
He doesn't stand an empirical test.
Disney experientially validated as we
see from the political landscape now.
And I worry that we may in the future.
So,
uh,
I,
I'm so disappointed that the subject is
just revolved around academia,
which was predictable because that's the
sort of crucible in which these elements
of mixed,
but even more disappointed that really I
haven't heard from Michelle or from
professor docent as to what they think
political greatness is because what
they've talked about is basically saying
progress in,
in our view is progress.
Well,
I agree.
That's,
you know.
Yeah.
So it is true and good on progress,
but how is it
you're saying political that what we
call the digital greatness you call
progress.
That's what you're supposed to be
arguing.
I want to know what you mean by
political correctness.
Well,
like I said though,
the reason a few months ago,
right,
you,
you contacted me,
asked if I wanted to do a debate about
identity politics and then you presented
me with this resolution and I said,
well,
there's a lot of things that people call
political correctness that I'm not going
to defend.
But then I realized who I was debating
and saw that there was a lot of things
that you,
Jordan Peterson called political
correctness that I call progress.
Um,
and,
and to some extent you to Stephen Fry,
you know,
when you talk about it being outrageous
to tear it out or not outrageous,
so I won't put words in your mouth,
but that we shouldn't be tearing down
statues of kind of notorious racist that
we should just instead be throwing exit
then,
you know,
so those sorts of things,
if you call them political correctness,
like call them progress now,
this feeling of being silenced,
which I understand,
although it seems very vague,
right?
You kind of are not quite putting your
finger on who was silencing you except
for a vague fear that if you say
something untoward,
you're going to be the subject of,
I'm not sure shaming biker who but by,
by what?
By the Internet.
No,
but I mean there's that element of it
hear what I'm saying is that it's,
it's a feeling.
It's a feeling that is this sort of
intangible result of on nearly
Goldstein the sort of show trial thing
where the person that apologizes,
I have so much to learn about sexual
politics.
I am really sorry.
Signed a lawyer,
crossed out the name of the
personally.
It's do you think
the real mistake of our left is that we
underestimate the right,
the right season to stupid as we'd like
them to be if only they were only there
went to coming to slide,
so smart,
so aware of our shortcomings and,
and,
and I just fear that political
correctness is a weapon that they value.
The more,
the more we tell the world how people
should be treated,
how language should be treated,
what words are acceptable,
what attitudes are,
what hr meeting is going to tell you in
a long bullet pointed list about how you
look at people.
All of this is meat and drink too bad
people to malefactors the bad actors are
not counting myself as one of those,
but does in that sense,
I mean bad actors in the other set.
Thank you.
So there are,
like I said,
there are a lot of ways in which I agree
with you,
although I kind of,
I,
I would like to hear.
I need to turn it back on you.
I'd like to hear you say,
you know,
what are the words that have fallen into
disrepute that we think that you think
we should be resurrecting?
Right.
A new to me,
this is this area of like hotly
contested social change right now.
We're a lot of people feel
but words that have gone into disuse.
It's very often phrases,
jargonistic slogans,
Hetero normative cisgendered,
those kinds of things that they're just
an insult.
You know,
imagine you're a young student arriving
university and someone's bombarding him
with this preposterous hermeneutical
nonsense from,
from,
from misread textbooks.
So Ms Dot red food code and they say
Derrida and,
and so on because.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know I was in Cambridge,
England doing it.
We had a French phase
value in that.
It's an interesting game and it is,
it's a place to,
uh,
I,
I think I just really say that the ghost
hovering over me is,
it's a letter Oscar Wilde roads and uh,
he,
he said [inaudible] love.
You said the fact that you didn't get
the degrees is nothing but you never
acquired what is sometimes called the
Oxford Manor.
And I'll say for that,
the university manner,
he said,
Oscar said,
I take that to mean the ability to play
gracefully with ideas.
I think that's disappearing from our
culture.
And I think it's an
thank you.
It's hard to beat a self deprecating
English minutes.
No,
no,
no.
I've got a pretty good idea here today.
But what's interesting,
I don't recall in all of you,
all of us have studied history.
I don't recall these debates about
political correctness happening when
people who were in power in absolute
power,
unquestioned power,
political correctness,
political correctness becomes an issue.
And what I mean by that is people who
used to have power,
who,
who still have power,
but they don't who gets challenged.
I'll just a little bit of what they have
and don't want to share toys in the sand
lot of life.
So all of a sudden it becomes a kind of
exaggerated grievance.
Now the things you named the bullet
points and the CIS gender,
the Hetero normativity and the Hetero
patriarchy,
and the capitalist resurgence and the
insurrection of subjugated knowledge is
to give some more love or the iridium
deconstruction.
All that stuff,
the French phase is still going on with
the French fries in America.
What's interesting is that I didn't hear
many complaints of political
correctness.
I'm at the height of the dominance of
one group or another,
but when Martin Luther King Jr,
who argued for group identity as a black
person to provide an opportunity for
individual black people to come to the
fore,
they began to make that claim.
Oh,
that didn't call it political
correctness.
You're siding with those who are against
free speech.
You're siding with those who don't want
me as a white person to be recognized in
my humanity,
and what I mean by political correctness
is the kind of politics of resentment
that are articulated by various holders
of power at certain levels,
at various levels.
That one of the beautiful things about
co that I take as opposed to Max Faber
is that full said power breaks out
everywhere.
I would think a person who's critical
political correctness like you would
appreciate this as opposed to Max Faber
who said power is over there in a
hierarchical structure where
subordination is the demand for coset.
No power brakes out,
even among people who are in
disempowered so you can hurt somebody in
your own community.
What's more politically incorrect than a
black baptist preacher?
Identifying with a first century
Palestinian Jew and still loving
atheist?
What's more politically incorrect in a
black intellectual going on Bill Maher
and offending his ability to continue to
have this show despite using the inward.
I serve believe in a politically
incorrect version when I go into the
Black Baptist preacher to chastise my
fellow believers about their homophobia
that goes over like a brick cloud.
When I come into arenas like this,
I understand that my back is up against
the wall,
but I think
sit over here.
Let's say I want to sit on your lap,
but what I say get excited,
but what I'm saying does that he goes
out and looking at me.
What's interesting
is that when we look at the way in which
we have societies in a free,
a Canadian society and the free American
society,
when I look at what is seen as political
correctness,
it to me has been a mass of jumble that
has been carved together out of the
politics of resentment that powers once
held,
no longer are held.
Freedoms once exercise absolutely must
now be shared.
So I,
I am in agreeance with both of my,
my gentleman to my right,
who believe that political correctness
has been a scourge,
but not necessarily the way you think,
so I think has been a scourge because
those who have been the deployers of
power and the beneficiaries of privilege
have failed to recognize their
particular way and at the end of the
day,
I think that those of us who are free
citizens of this country and of America
should figure out ways to respect the
humanity of the other,
to respect the individual existence of
the other,
but also respect the fact that there
have been barriers placed upon
particular groups that have prevented
them from flourishing.
That's all I mean by political,
correct.
Well said.
I got to give before we get to closing
statements and final words on this topic
to Michelle and then,
uh,
you,
Jordan.
So I think part of the frustration here
is that I think that both of you have
radically different ideas of what we're
talking about when we talk about
political correctness.
It seems to me that you're talking about
politically correctness.
You mean this kind of feeling of anxiety
that a lot of people feel because we all
live now in this terrible crowdsource
panopticon when you worried that any
straight phrase that you use will be any
stray phrase you utter might be used to
define you.
Right?
And I think that a lot of people feel
that anxiety.
I,
I disagree that that is something that
is being solely,
kind of perpetrated against,
you know,
institution to kind of Oscar Wilde and
figures by a sensory and sensory is left
wing chord because it's coming from all
directions,
right?
This phenomenon,
which sucks is all over the place.
I mean,
I get it when I write something critical
of the way that the IDF behaved in Gaza,
you know,
it,
it's coming at everyone and I think that
there is,
there's a way in which when it comes at
a certain sort of figure and there's a
certain set of complaints and you feel
unjustly criticized and feel silenced,
which again I think is really different
than being silenced.
You call it political correctness and I
would like the culture also to be more
freewheeling.
I think one solution,
you know,
you're not going to kind of get the left
to um,
I don't know.
They can't kind of put an end to this
because it is much more of a mob social
media phenomenon than it is kind of some
diktat coming up from on high.
And so one really the only way to break
through it is to say what you are,
what you say that you're afraid to say,
right?
I mean that's the only way to sort of
pop this bubble or kind of end this end,
this anxiety or at least diffuse it a
little bit.
Whereas again,
what I hear Mr Peterson talking about as
political correctness is something much
more broad and much more,
um,
kind of funded,
much,
much more fundamental to social change
and you're talking about,
you know,
you want
me to define or one of us to talk about
when the left goes too far and if I'm,
you know,
I certainly don't want to be a woman
putting words in your mouth,
but if I'm,
if I hear you correctly,
what you're saying is that you want me
to kind of renounce Marxist categories
or to.
Well,
I want you to define with the left goes
too far.
You can do it any way you want.
I,
like I said,
I think that the left goes too far into
when it is violent or censorious when it
tries to shut people down or no platform
them or when it asked violently I,
I'm not sure what you expect.
Something beyond that.
Something deeper.
How like you to contend with the set of
left wing ideas that produced all the
lift wing pathologies of the 20th
century and to define how you think
standard left wing thinking,
which has a place where it goes too far
since it obviously does gone too far.
Of course the right.
Tell us how well.
How about Auschwitz,
about justice center?
What else?
More recently,
what has gone wrong with the right?
Don't like identity politics players at
all.
I don't care whether they're on the left
or the right.
I'd be lecturing about right wing
extremism for 30 years.
I'm no fan of the right.
Despite the fact that the left would
like to paint me that way because it's
more convenient for reasonably well
where it's threatening to go to foreign
identitarian Europe,
that's for sure.
It's gone too far in Charlottesville.
It went too far in Norway.
Like how long the list do you want and
why am I required to produce that to
show you that I don't like the terrios
thought I'd ask you.
I was actually asking you what your
assumption is.
How that I must be on the site.
If the right,
it's like,
look,
the right has an occupied the humanities
and the social sciences.
It's as simple as that.
For me,
if they had,
I'd be objecting to them.
Say that again.
I didn't have the right.
Has not occupied the social sciences and
the humanities and the left clearly has
the statistical evidence for that is
overwhelming.
So what about Iq testing in terms of
genetic inheritance.
We're here to talk about political,
correct?
Yes.
And we've done a damn thing.
I gave you an example.
Can Redeem ourselves with our closing
statements are going to put three
minutes on the clock.
We're going to go in the reverse order
of the opening.
So Steven,
Europe first.
Oh Lordy,
Lordy,
hide behind the legs.
And in that case,
well,
I've been fascinated by this
conversation.
There's been an enormous clash of
cultures in,
in the conversation we've had,
you know,
classic,
if I can call it huckstering snake oil
pulpit talk.
It's a motive
discourse.
It's a rhetorical style that I find
endlessly refreshing vivifying.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm not sure that we actually focused
on,
on the point in question.
And my objection has always been towards
orthodoxy.
I'm a,
I'm a heterodox and a contrarian and I
can't help myself.
And I think there's been an
underestimation of the fact that
language does affect people.
It does make the young in particular,
is this starting out on their
educational or their work careers.
It makes them,
it makes them very anxious.
It makes them very angry,
very upset,
very alienated to feel that they don't
know anymore how to operate in the
world,
how to engage in relationships,
how to think honestly.
So they they create more and more to
their own mini groups and I think that's
dangerous and unhappy for society.
I think it's reflected in the paucity of
cinema and literature and art and the
culture generally is that there's a fear
that's pervading it and while people can
talk to academia and so you should come
see our lessons.
Our lectures are open and free and ideas
are exchanged.
I'm sure that's true.
I'm sure it's true,
but I don't think we should
underestimate how much this feeling is
prevalent in the culture of this strange
paradox that the liberals are liberal in
the demand for liberality.
They are exclusive in that demand for
inclusivity.
They are homogenous in their demand for
heterogeneity.
They are somehow and diverse in the call
for diversity.
You can be diverse but not diverse in
your opinions and in your language and
then your behavior and that's okay.
Terrible pity.
I,
I would say that I'm,
I'm sorry that it got a bit heated,
uh,
in places because I was hoping it
wouldn't.
I was hoping would be a shining example
of how people of all different kinds of
political outlooks can speak with humor
and wit and a lightness of touch.
As gk Chesterton said,
angels can fly because they take
themselves lightly.
And I think it's very important for us
who are privileged.
All four of us are privileged to be
here,
to be asked to be here,
to take ourselves a little bit more
likely not to be too earnest,
too pompous to serious a and not to be
too certain.
Uh,
it's,
it's a time,
I think for really engaging,
emotionally fulfilling,
passionate and positive doubt.
That's what I would.
Thank you.
We're going to put minutes on the clock
for
you please.
Uh,
your closing.
Thank you so much for that compliment.
I'm used to not exclusively white men
who see black intelligence articulated
at a certain level of feeling a kind of
condescension if I came up here,
ms.dot.
I was saying the other day,
but,
but a kind of verbal facility
automatically assumed to be a kind of
hucksterism and snake oil salesmen.
I've seen that.
I get it.
I get hate letters every day from white
brothers and sisters who were mad.
I'm teaching their children.
You're just trying to coopt our
children.
You're trying to corrupt them.
Yes.
I'm trying to corrupt them so they will
be uncorrupted by the corruptibility
that they've inherited from a society
that refuses to see all people as human
beings.
The death threats I've received
constantly for simply trying to speak my
mind.
It's not about a politically correct
society that is open minded.
Uh,
and that has some consternation about my
ability to speak.
I'm getting real live.
You want empirical death threats that
talk about killing me,
setting up to hurt me and harm me simply
because I choose to speak my mind.
I agree with my confreres in my
compatriots that we should argue against
the vicious limitation and recursions
against speech.
I believe that everybody has the right
to be able to articulate themselves and
the enormous privilege we have to come
to a spot in a space like this means
that we have that privilege and we
should be responsible for it.
No matter where we go from here,
me and brother Peterson will go to a
black Baptist church.
I'm gonna.
Hold him to that.
He said it on national TV.
We're going to go to a black Baptist
church and have an enlightening
conversation about the need for us to
engage in not only reciprocal and mutual
edification,
but criticism,
even hard and tough criticism,
but in a way that speaks to the needs
and interests of those who don't usually
get on TV,
who's voices are not usually amplified,
whose ideas are not usually taken
seriously and when they get to the upper
echelons of the ability of a society to
express themselves,
they are equally subject too vicious
recrimination and hurtful resistance.
There's old story about the pig and the
pig and the chicken going down the
street and said,
let's have breakfast.
The chicken just has to give up an egg.
The pig has to give up his ass in order
to make breakfast.
We have often been the pigs giving up
our assets to make breakfast.
Let's start sharing them.
Asses what everybody else.
Thank you.
Thanks.
So I'm not here to claim that there's no
such thing as oppression,
unfairness brutality,
discrimination,
unfair
use of power.
All of those.
Anyone with any sense knows that
hierarchical structures tilt towards
tyranny and that we have to be
constantly wakeful to ensure that all
they are isn't power in tyranny.
It's interesting to see here food foodco
referred to.
It's unfortunate,
but it's interesting because coal like
is French intellectual confreres
essentially believed that the only basis
upon which hierarchies were established
his power,
and that's part of this pernicious
politically correct doctrine that I've
been speaking about.
When a hierarchy becomes corrupt,
then the only way to ascend it is to
exercise power.
That's essentially the definition of a
tyranny,
but that doesn't mean that the imperfect
hierarchies that we have constructed in
our relatively free countries,
which at least tilt somewhat towards
competence and ability as evidenced by
the staggering achievements of
civilization that we've managed to
produce.
It doesn't mean that the appropriate way
of diagnosing them as to assume without
reservation unit dimensionally that
they're all about power and as a
consequence,
everyone who occupies any position
within them is a tyrant or tyrant in the
making.
And that is certainly the fundamental
claim of someone like food co and it's
part and parcel of this.
What would you call it?
This ideological catastrophe.
That's political correctness.
I'm not here to argue against progress.
I'm not here to argue against equality
of opportunity.
Anyone with any sense understands that
even if you're selfish,
you're best served by allowing yourself
access to the multiplicitous talents of
everyone and to discriminate against
them for arbitrary reasons unrelated to
their competencies.
It's a board that has nothing to do with
the issue at hand.
It's it.
It isn't that good.
Things haven't happened in the past and
should continue to happen.
That's not the point.
The point is the point my compatriot
fried made,
which is what we can agree on the
catastrophe and we can agree on the
historical inequity,
but there's no way I'm going to agree
that political correctness is the way to
address any of that and there's plenty
of evidence to the contrary.
Some of which I would say was displayed
quite clearly tonight.
Thank you.
So I think one of the irresolvable
issues that we're all coming up against
is the role of feelings,
right?
Stephen Fry is kind of asked us to
recognize and empathize with this
feeling of being silenced.
Of being threatened and I do and I get
it.
Um,
you know,
I feel it sometimes too in my columns.
I hate it when I write something that
then gets that kind of irate twitter mob
after me.
But if say I stood up here and said,
you know,
recognize how threatened so many women
feel when,
for example,
the,
the kind of,
you know,
one of the best selling and most
prominent intellectuals in the world
right now says in an interview that
maybe the me too movement has shown that
this whole experiment of men and women
working together,
it's just not working.
Or you know,
maybe if women don't want to be.
I don't want the workplace to be
sexualized.
They shouldn't be allowed to wear
makeup.
Right?
Sorry,
the,
well,
google it,
Google it.
Um,
so,
right.
If I say like,
you know,
I feel threatened,
right?
Then I'm being kind of politically
correct and hysterical.
So much of the debate about political.
Correct.
But there's one group that really does
think it's feeling should be
accommodated.
And that is what we keep coming up
against is that,
you know,
there's a group of people and to some
extent I'm part of it,
that feels uniquely that our feelings of
being silenced or marginalized,
censored.
That those feelings need to take
primacy,
that we can kind of,
um,
you know,
sneer when these other groups for us to
take seriously their feelings of being
threatened or their feelings of being
marginalized.
Then we call it,
we call that we call those demands
political correctness.
And I would finally say that I think
there is a fair amount of research that
people become more closed minded,
more tribal when they feel threatened,
when they feel that their group identity
is at stake.
And so as much as you know,
you want to blame the left for the rise
of the right.
I think that when you kind of bet the
rise of the right,
the rise of people who are questioning
the fundamental ideals of pluralistic
liberal democracy,
the more of those views are
mainstreamed.
The more people I think are going to
shut down in response because people are
really scared.
Thank you.
First of all,
I think
all the debaters I think we want to
thank the audience you were engaged were
mostly civil and lots of civil in ways.
I think that we enjoy it,
so I think on behalf of the debaters
everybody.
Thank you audience.
This was a challenging topic.
Great job.
You
too.
Our debaters know it's one thing.
All of these four give regular speeches,
but it's a very different thing to come
on and into stage in front of a live
audience,
a large television,
and have your ideas a contested in real
time.
And,
uh,
again to all four of you.
Thank you for accepting our invitation
to
come here to thank a few final notes.
First,
thank you to the foundation and the monk
family for once again convening us here
at Roy Thompson Hall.
We're going to do it all again this
coming autumn.
All of you have a ballot here in the
hall.
You can vote on your way out.
We'll have those results for you just
probably after nine,
15.
And let's just quickly review where your
opinions stood at the beginning of
tonight's contest on the motion.
Be it resolved what I call political
correctness,
what you call it,
political correctness.
I call progress.
Thirty six percent agrees.
Sixty four percent disagree.
And again,
we saw a large percentage of you willing
to change your mind 87 percent.
So let's see how tonight's cut and
thrust affected your voting here you've
got your ballots.
And again,
to those of you who are watching online,
we are going to have all these results
for you on our social media feeds around
9:15.
So enjoy the long weekend.
Happy Victoria Day everyone.
Thanks for coming out
the munk debates
and Stephen Fry Right now to get their
reactions to tonight's debate.
Uh,
so ma hotly contested moments here.
So it would be curious to see what
happens with the audience.
Vote over the course of the next few
minutes.
And also for those of you watching
online,
we have that are running poll.
That poll again was ww munk debates.com
forward slash boats.
So go there,
check it out,
see how each of these debaters did in
terms of their opening statements that
are rebuttals.
The moderated section in the closing
statements,
we see any changes
there.
So again,
we're going to go right now to Stephen
Fry,
Jordan Peterson,
get their thoughts on how the evening
played out.
Gentlemen,
thank you.
Thank you both.
We're just gonna do a quick discussion
with the online audience who's watching
right now just to get your reactions to
the debate and maybe to start with you.
Uh,
Jordan.
There were some heated moments here.
Did that,
that surprise you,
that a exchanges that you had with
Michael Eric Dyson?
Well,
I wouldn't say it surprised me.
I suppose it probably did.
It just seem didn't seem like a very
good tactical move and I stand by what I
said.
I don't see any reason at all that my
racial identity needed to be dragged
into the discussion,
the independent of my personality
proclivity.
I would say what I just said to Mr Frye
here is that it was a pleasure sharing
the stage with him.
I've rarely heard anyone ever deliver
their convictions with such a remarkable
sense of passion.
And we have 10 forbearance and
erudition.
It was,
it was really something.
And Steven,
the challenging debate because in a
sense we're trying to mesh two different
views here,
two different worldviews,
one very focused more on identity
politics,
group identity.
You in a sense having an argument really
more about the larger culture itself and
the tenor and tone of the conversation
with the DM is being a little kind of
scuffled gum really in the.
It's got the gun and two specific that I
just taken very literally the popular
idea that greatness as being a kind of
control of language and the shutting
down and phrases or an introduction of
others and the kind of day to day as
they say,
human resource departments of
corporations and that sort of thing.
And so I was slightly disappointed that
it just became a debate about race and
about gender and so on.
But that was,
I guess not true and I still didn't
know.
The fact is I,
I,
I'm still a lefty but a software.
I'm just don't have to soft squishy in
every sentence.
And I realized that that's not a
political point of view.
It is a personal and the gap between the
personal and the political,
which is space you obviously very
interested in is as a psychologist is
one that is rarely explored a few people
that are either so personal that it has
no application in the outside world and
the Organization of Human Affairs or the
soap or the decal and so much to do with
structure and distinction between
hierarchies and networks and so on that
they forget the individual and that's
the space in which the impassionate
liberal lives and it's not easy to do it
because you often do sound rather wet
and I'm aware that I,
I enjoyed it.
Thank you for coming.
You just finally,
before I,
for you to both to a well earned drank
a,
anything left unsaid.
Jordan,
any,
um,
any point that you wanted to make that,
uh,
you didn't feel you had the time or the
opportunity?
No,
I think so.
I said my piece.
Yeah.
Great.
Same question to you is do you know,
I think I heard got across,
I mean there's so much you can talk
about in,
in,
in that field,
and I just wanted to leave with the
point that I do want,
like everybody,
it's,
it's a no brainer.
We want the world to be fairer,
Justa,
sweeter kinder.
Um,
but it's how you get the a and m.
I felt like I wasn't really addressed.
Okay.
Well gentlemen,
thank you both very much from our online
audience.
A big thank you.
Also,
I know Jordan Peterson and Stephen Fry
for participating in A.
Yeah,
in a debate with some steaks on the
table for sure.
Thank you gentlemen.
See seeing the reception you,
but again,
online viewers.
We've now have Michael Eric dyson coming
into the camera range here with Michelle
Goldberg to get their reactions to the
debate.
So guys,
thank you for being part of this.
You know,
it's a,
it's a complicated subjects.
It's got a lot of different moving
pieces and elements.
I think we addressed some of the
constituent parts.
Maybe start with you,
Michelle.
Was there something on stage that you
wanted to say that maybe we didn't have
the time or you didn't have the
opportunity?
Uh,
you know,
now's your chance.
Well,
you know,
I guess I,
the only thing I can think of is that
maybe I wished that we could have
drilled down a little bit more into the
gender piece of this and again too,
you know,
what we're really arguing about,
um,
particularly with Mr Peterson and the
kind of range of progress,
the range of feminist progress that he
considers political correctness.
I think part of the frustration is that
him and Steven Fry are talking about and
defending,
I think a fairly discrete set of ideas
with some overlap.
Um,
you know,
in,
one of the difficult things about
political correctness is it's a slippery
term that's deployed to talk about a
whole range of phenomenon and
closed down conversation and open up
conversation.
How did you feel a Michael?
There were some points.
There are some points of sharp exchange.
We appreciate that at the munk debates.
I mean,
this is not a place for,
for a shrinking wallflowers,
but,
uh,
any unsaid thoughts,
any,
anything that you want to put a point on
now,
I think you have to hold people
intellectually accountable and to deny
some of the things to Michelle that he
said and to present himself Mr Peterson
in a certain way without seeing some of
the important things he said about women
and other minorities I think demands an
engaged response to him.
And I think that the idea itself,
as Michelle stated repeatedly and,
and Mr Fried talked about his
frustration.
He said,
we've talked about everything but
political correctness.
Well,
the reality is political correctness
resides.
I mean rests upon some serious political
work in this culture in the UK,
Canada,
and in America that needs to be done.
And what I tried to,
in terms of giving a brief genealogy,
we didn't have political correctness as
long as white,
straight men were in charge.
There was no argument about let's get
this right.
But when people who exercise power,
no longer exercise,
absolute power,
still predominant power,
then there's an argument and I think
Michelle's point about gender,
about the workplace,
about race,
about sexuality and the lake.
I just think that it was a necessarily
vigorous and sometimes sharply worded a
debate between the.
So Michelle,
final word to you.
Well,
if you are curious about the quote that
I mentioned about,
you know,
maybe this experiment with women and men
working together.
Maybe it's not working.
I mean please do Google it.
It's an interview with vice columns for
doing one of your colleagues.
But again,
I didn't know me and Steven,
me and Stephen Fry probably could have
sat on the same side of another debate.
But again,
I feel like the phrase political
correctness has expanded to cover a
whole range of challenges too.
I thought it was really interesting how
much people were talking about their
feelings because when,
when women talk about their feelings,
right?
That is politically correct.
Excess.
And when,
when men talk about this feeling that
they can't empirically define,
we should all,
I guess,
I don't know,
change,
change in deference to that.
Okay guys,
great thoughts.
Let's go get a drink and the reception
that.
Thank you.
I'm buying.
Okay.
Thanks.
Thanks again.
Hey,
uh,
online viewers.
Thank you for being part of this monk
debates.
Uh,
as I mentioned these debates or
semiannual,
we'll have another one this fall.
We've got a whole archive of past
debates on our website on a whole range
of topics going back over a decade now.
And you can access those free by simply
becoming a member@wwmunkdebates.com.
Go to the basic membership.
It's free.
And we have a rock solid privacy policy
there.
We respect your privacy.
So finally,
check us out on,
on facebook.
Thank you for the 26,000
new follows in the last 10 days.
We appreciate it.
This debate will be archived on our
website for the next while,
again for free.
So share it with friends and family.
I'm your Griffis from downtown Toronto,
Canada at the monk debate on political
correctness.
See again in the autumn,
take care.
Good
night.